the average training program focuses on
a few key lifts and or losing weight
this is a great start but it leaves a
huge amount of your potential
performance untapped here are some
things missing from most training
programs rotational strength rotational
strength is strength in the transverse
plane I.E strength when twisting so many
real world activities involve movement
in this plane and yet we rarely use
exercises that Target this straight arm
strength straight arm strength is the
ability to generate strength with the
arms in a locked out position this is
useful for gymnastic moves but it can
also help to prevent elbow injuries when
lifting cognitive performance there are
many ways the brain can be trained this
is one of the next Frontiers for
optimizing Peak Performance among
athletes proprioception can you tilt
your pelvis protracts your scapular body
awareness is key for learning new
movements and generating power in a safe
way the list goes on from strength
endurance to lung capacity to emotional
control to balance to vision and hearing
grip strength and ambidexterity there's
no limit to what you can train and what
you can become
bye for now